اسمي أنتوني ماكدونالد وعمري
تسع سنوات وأنا من بروكلين
نيويورك وسؤالي هو ما كان موجودًا
للكون
أنثيا هذا سؤال رائع
والإجابة السريعة هي لا أحد يعرف ما كان
قبل الكون ولكن دعني فقط  أعطيك
فكرتين لذا فإن أحد الاحتمالات
هو أن الكون كان
موجودًا دائمًا وهذه فكرة غريبة صحيحة
لأننا اعتدنا على الأشياء التي
لها دائمًا بداية بشكل صحيح تم
إنشاء مدرستك ، فقد كان لديك بداية ولدت
لديك بداية ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر
قد يكون الكون أن الكون
لم يكن له بداية ، فقد كانت
الأشياء دائمًا في الكون والشمس والأرض
لها بداية ولكن
ربما كان الكل دائمًا هنا ،
والفكرة الثانية هي أنه ربما كان للكون
بداية ولكن  فكرة ما قبل
تلك البداية ربما لا يكون
لها أي معنى لأنه ربما
بدأ الوقت نفسه في بداية
الكون ، لذا كمقياس ، تخيل
أنك على كوكب الأرض وأنت تسأل
شخصًا ما كيف أذهب أبعد شمالًا ويشيرون
شمالًا تمشي في هذا
الاتجاه ، تمر بشخص آخر ، واسأله
كيف تذهب بعيدًا شمالًا ،
يشيرون إلى الاتجاه الشمالي ، لكن
عندما تصل إلى القطب الشمالي نفسه ، إذا
سألت شخصًا ما هناك كيف يمكنني الذهاب إلى
الشمال ، سيقولون أنه يمكنك  لن نذهب إلى
الشمال أكثر من القطب الشمالي ، فهذا
هو المكان الذي يبدأ فيه الشمال بالمثل ، فقد يكون الوقت قد
بدأ في بداية
الكون ، لذا إذا كان بإمكانك تخيل العودة
مائة عام إلى الوراء من اليوم ألف
عام ومليار سنة ولكن إذا ذهبت
مباشرة إلى  إن البدء بفكرة
العودة إلى الوراء في الزمن أكثر من
البداية قد لا تكون موجودة ، فقد لا يكون لها
أي معنى ، لذا فهذان
احتمالان للإجابة على
سؤالك ، لكن أنثيا ربما في يوم من الأيام
ستقدم إجابة عميقة على هذا السؤال
والأهم  من بين كل ذلك ، استمر في
طرح الأسئلة لأنها ما
يدفع التقدم وفهمنا للكون
[موسيقى]